how do you impeach a president that
question is on a lot of people's minds
and here's how it works
first the president has to screw up
Bigley the US Constitution considers
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors to be impeachable offenses
if the president commits any of these
Congress has the power to remove him or
her it all starts with the House of
Representatives members of the House can
introduce impeachment resolutions like
bills or the house could start the
process with an inquiry the Judiciary
Committee reviews the resolution or
inquiry findings and then recommends
whether or not to take the issue to the
floor that's when the house
representatives vote to move the
impeachment process forward if a simple
majority gives the green light that the
ball is in the Senate's court the Senate
acts as the jury for an impeachment
trial and the Senate chamber is the
courtroom the house selects some of its
members to act as prosecutors and in a
presidential impeachment the Chief
Justice of the US Supreme Court preside
after the arguments the Senate votes on
whether to convict the president this is
when a two-thirds vote is required and
the penalty for impeachment is removal
from office it's a complicated process
but it has happened most recently with
Bill Clinton in 1998 the house impeached
him for lying under oath to a federal
grand jury and obstructing justice
you know the whole not having sexual
relations with that woman thing but the
Senate later acquitted Clinton on both
charges and Deere made president before
that there was Richard Nixon's in 1974
the House Judiciary Committee
recommended that Nixon be impeached for
his involvement in the Watergate scandal
but Nixon resigned before the entire
house could vote and Andrew Johnson was
the first president to go through the
impeachment process in 1868 the house
impeached him after he fired a cabinet
member without Senate approval but
Johnson held on to power after the
Senate failed to convict him with a
two-thirds vote all three of these
presidents were impeached but Congress
never actually removed any of them from
office and with Congress playing such an
instrumental role chances of an
impeachment seem less likely when the
House the Senate and the president all
belonged to the same party but you never
know